[Música]
hoy 31 de mayo es el día mundial sin
tabaco esta celebración anual busca
informar y crear conciencia acerca de
los peligros que supone el consumo de
este producto y las prácticas
comerciales de las empresas tabacaleras
según datos de la organización mundial
de la salud además de tener un impacto
nocivo en nuestra salud el tabaco genera
toneladas de desechos que destruyen los
bosques también contribuye al
calentamiento global vamos entonces a
repasar algunos datos sobre el tabaco la
oms se calcula que 8.2 millones de
personas pierden la vida a raíz del
trabajo cada año de estos 7 millones son
por ser fumadores directos y 1.2
fumadores indirectos en el continente
americano casi la mitad de esas muertes
ocurren por las enfermedades
respiratorias crónicas mientras que
aproximadamente el 25 por ciento se debe
al cáncer vamos ahora a ver otro gráfico
que hemos preparado para ustedes en la
batalla para conversar para convencer
que el tabaco es malo para la salud uno
de los principales oponentes ha sido
precisamente la industria del tabaco una
industria que invierte 8 mil millones de
dólares anuales en publicidad también
según la base aumentar un 10% el precio
del tabaco por ejemplo a través de los
impuestos ayudaría a disminuir en un 45
por ciento por ciento el consumo total
de este producto es decir del tabaco
para analizar entonces estos datos
entender un poco más sobre lo dañina que
es esta industria para la salud humana y
también para el medio ambiente quiero
darle la bienvenida a la doctora adriana
blanco omar quiso ya es jefa de la
secretaría del convenio en el marco de
la oms para el control del tabaco
gracias doctora por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de francia 24
hablemos entonces del impacto al daño
real que genera el tabaco para nuestra
salud
bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación y bueno realmente el impacto
de la salud es el más conocido pero no
el único como usted mismo ha mencionado
el impacto es en todos los órganos del
cuerpo han y es uno de los principales
factores de riesgo para las enfermedades
no transmisibles que son la principal
causa de muerte a nivel mundial son
realmente eliminar el consumo de tabaco
sería muy importante para disminuir la
mortalidad prematura por enfermedades no
transmisibles como se puede disminuir
doctora este consumo de tabaco digamos
que política se pudiera tomar realmente
los gobiernos o la organización mundial
de la salud para hacer esta disminución
efectiva además como también digamos
luchar de alguna manera con esta
industria tan fuerte tan poderosa como
es la industria tabacalera con un lobby
tan amplio no
bueno justamente para eso los estados
miembros de la oms se adoptaron y
tenemos
fuerza desde hace más de 16 años el
convenio marco de la oms para el control
del tabaco que justamente provee todas
las medidas que son efectivas y muchas
de ellas son las que la que usted está
mostrando por ejemplo medidas que pueden
pueden disminuir la demanda como son la
previsión de fumar en lugares públicos
las advertencias sanitarias y el
empaquetado sencillo de las cajetillas
el aumento de impuestos como usted
perfectamente mencionó al inicio ayudar
a las personas a poder dejar de fumar
porque desafortunadamente esto es una
una adicción y prohibir toda la
publicidad promoción y patrocinio que
como usted dice
justamente la industria invierte una
cantidad de dinero que es casi
inimaginable para la mayoría de las
personas ahora doctora adriana también
la bbc este año se enfocó en el medio
ambiente también un impacto que tiene no
sólo en nuestra salud individual sino
también en el medio ambiente y quiero ir
con unos datos la industria cuesta
anualmente 600 millones de árboles 200
mil hectáreas de tierra 22 mil toneladas
de agua y emite 84 mil millones de
toneladas de co2 como poder
contrarrestar también todo esto son unas
cifras realmente impactantes
si son y normalmente esta parte no se no
se considera y hay otros daños por
ejemplo hoy día la ciencia está
preocupada por el tema de los plásticos
y la existencia de micro plásticos que
se pueden encontrar en n ahora en el
organismo humano y bueno recordemos que
los filtros están hechos de celulosa y
son realmente un contaminante uno de los
contaminantes más frecuentes que podemos
encontrar por ejemplo en las playas en
los océanos estos micro plásticos no se
degradan no desaparecen del medio
ambiente en una forma adecuada y bueno
son son entran dentro de el organismo de
los peces algunos de ellos nosotros los
ingerimos juntos el pez y algunos
simplemente mueren por la cantidad de
tóxicos que estos filtros presentan
claro digamos que también el problema
más allá del humo está en esas llamadas
colillas de cigarros como ustedes lo
dijo contaminan millones de litros
cúbicos de litros de agua pues
anualmente no también doctora le quería
preguntar el 80 por ciento de los
fumadores está en países de ingresos
bajos y medios porque esta cifra
bueno si bien el consumo de tabaco
empezó antes en los países desarrollados
también el control del tabaco comenzó
antes en los países desarrollados
entonces la industria ha ido moviéndose
según sus necesidades buscando países
con menor regulación con menores
obstáculos para su economía la economía
de la industria no no la del país
y justamente es por eso que ha ido
llegando a estos países pero lo bueno es
que el convenio marco se ha demostrado
que se puede implementar en los países
en desarrollo y que cuando se implementa
en una forma completa realmente se
reduce la cantidad de fumadores en ese
país en esos países doctora también
usted habla de esta digamos reinvención
pues este movimiento de la industria
tabacalera y lo vemos también sobre todo
en estos últimos meses en estos últimos
años con los cigarros electrónicos con
el llamado mapeo cuál es la diferencia
de consumir un tabaco como lo conocemos
tradicionalmente y uno para peo porque
también hay gente que dice pues no yo
prefiero vapear que es menos nocivo para
la salud que no me hace tanto daño
incluso de personas que piensan que eso
pues no tienen un impacto nocivo para la
salud yo quisiera entonces que hagamos
como también esa diferencia y también
hablemos de qué impacto tiene para
nuestra salud para nuestros pulmones
hacer este papel
bueno lo cierto es que hoy día la
ciencia independiente o sea no la que es
producida por las personas que producen
los cigarrillos electrónicos no es
conclusiva para poder de afirmar ciento
por ciento de que estos productos son
menos dañinos sabemos perfectamente que
no están exentos de riesgos ok eso está
claro si son menos dañinos que el tabaco
no está claro pero hay un problema la
industria está un poco confundiendo
digamos a la opinión pública porque
primero que todo ponen en una misma
bolsa de bateo dos grandes tipos de
productos uno son los cigarrillos
electrónicos lo que nosotros llamamos
sistemas electrónicos de liberación de
nicotina y los otros son los productos
de tabaco calentado que son diferentes
porque los productos de tabaco
calentados son productos de tabaco ok es
una forma más donde la industria
presenta estos productos recordemos que
la industria hace muchísimos años empezó
a presentar los filtros como una forma
de reducir el daño lo que sabemos que
los filtros y filtran pero no filtran
todo lo que lo que el fumador saca y aún
con filtro los cigarrillos son mortales
después de los filtros empezó con la con
las experiencias de los cigarrillos
light low mail que realmente lo único
que tienen son agujeritos en los filtros
que hace cuando las máquinas miden y
miden de sus componentes son - porque se
diluye con el aire que entra por los por
los agujeritos pero las personas que
fuman fuman por la cantidad de nicotina
que tienen que sacar porque es lo que
los hace adictos por lo tanto para el
que fuma lo va a fumar de una forma que
obtiene la misma cantidad de componentes
después crearon algunos productos que
dicen que son de riesgo reducido y
tuvieron que sacarlos del
mercado porque no eran para nada
reducidos y ahora tenemos esta nueva ola
digamos de productos realmente como digo
son productos que todavía son adictivos
hay ciertos componentes en los
cigarrillos electrónicos que están en
menos cantidad pero desafortunadamente
para la salud no para algunos de esos
productos no hay un
límite que no pueda decir por debajo de
éstos no son riesgosos porque muchos de
los carcinógenos son riesgosos en
cualquier cantidad
lamentablemente no hay suficiente
evidencia para recomendar estos
productos
doctora también en todo caso después e
inhalar cualquier tipo de humo siempre
va a ser nocivo para nuestra salud
cierto sí claro y específicamente porque
la los productores de estos productos
valga la redundancia hablan de vapor y
cuando uno siente vapor uno piensa esto
que sale de la caldera no cuando una
calienta agua no no es eso es un es un
aerosol que contiene sustancias tóxicas
o sea no es vapor de agua ok es un
aerosol con sustancias químicas y con
sustancias químicas que no están
presentes en los cigarrillos
convencionales algunas de ellas porque
hasta ahora nadie sabe qué pasa cuando
una inhala papel en glee con la que
nosotros usamos con como aditivos
de cosas que se pueden comer pero nadie
sabe qué pasa cuando uno inhala esas
sustancias por lo tanto yo creo que hay
que tener la precaución nosotros lo que
queremos es que disminuya el consumo de
tabaco en general y no queremos crear
otra nueva adicción que dentro de 20
años tengamos que decir oh esto es un
problema otra vez estamos enfrentados
con un producto activo que produce
enfermedades y que podríamos haber
evitado hace unos años el convenio-marco
es efectivo para disminuir el consumo de
tabaco y muchos gente está diciendo no
no es efectivo porque tenemos un millón
mil millones 200 fumadores en forma
constante de hace años sí pero
recordemos que en el 2005 cuando el
tratado entró en vigor teníamos una
prevalencia de 29.5 por ciento de
fumadores si aplicamos esa prevalencia a
la población de hoy porque la aprobación
sigue creciendo tendríamos 1.700
millones de fumadores quiere decir que
si estamos disminuyendo el número de
fumadores doctora y también para seguir
hablando en esa infinidad de productos
que contienen la nicotina no que al
final de cuentas es como esta sustancia
adictiva que contiene estos productos
con tabaco pues tenemos los parches los
chicles no para obviamente saciar esa
necesidad de nicotina de los fumadores
que tan nociva es la nicotina en nuestra
salud no
bueno la nicotina tiene algunos aspectos
digamos que la mayor parte de la lo
nocivo de los cigarrillos combustibles
está en los alquitranes ok y eso se
produce con cualquier combustión el
problema con la nicotina si la nicotina
tiene riesgos cardiovasculares y no nos
olvidemos que el principal riesgo de
principal enfermedad que está matando en
el mundo son las enfermedades
cardiovasculares y la nicotina tiene
efectos en estos en estos aspectos la
nicotina también tiene un efecto
favorecedor de los cánceres no es que
los produzca pero sí lo favorece y lo
que es importante en la nicotina tiene
efectos nocivos en en el cerebro en
desarrollo y esto es importante cuando
consideramos que la gente que empieza
con estos productos empieza en edades
muy muy muy tempranas digamos niños 13
14 15 años
exclusivos para el cerebro digamos en el
área cognitiva autora si en el área
cognitiva